i've been super hard on kicked out the  last five months and like for anybody  that doubts it  i had something go over a million views  like literally zero that piece of  content that you had get a million you  should milk the living [ __ ] out of that  what most people do is try to find the  next one what we don't do is squeeze the  [ __ ] out of the viral post that one post  you should get into shorts you should  set up your facebook fan page because of  it it should you should do it three more  times on instagram in stories twitter  this like it should be like squeeze the  [ __ ] out of that virality  and i might even push it harder just to  make it really a good part of jab jab  jab left hook because i don't even need  to test it i know the answer which is if  i just go back and re-post because we do  it occasionally and re-post the 30 most  successful posts i've had in my career  today nine years later four years later  they're gonna [ __ ] crush